have you have you seen this post from
this guy is uh grantbe911
he's one of the founders of breaking911
and he tweeted
my daughter just started second grade at
metro schools i will be pulling her out
immediately her first english lesson of
the year is teaching her that white
people are bad
mean and racist against
african-americans and mexicans my
daughter is seven
is not racist nor is her family this
stuff is
has become so pervasive across the board
that i feel like you know the position
i'm in right now is
the only thing that stops this and i
don't even know if it will is
a straight republican super majority
victory to just
push this insanity out this is what
happens
when the only thing you're allowed to
say is this
like you can't think about what 4chan
did with that campaign you ever see that
campaign it's okay to be white
yeah the goal of that was to point out
that
the establishment our mainstream society
is so insane
that you can't even say it's okay to be
white
no they call it white supremacy straight
up there there's a there's a funny photo
of uh it's like three hispanic dudes a
white guy and a black guy
and the far left posts the photo saying
white supremacists
it's this is this is our brains are
broken like
not not ours says the brains of society
completely fractured at this point
as far as i can tell i'm scared about
the upcoming school season
i mean you know it's like we got
pictures check this out
the white kids told the mexican girl to
go back to the mexican school it says
and they have these images
this is what they're teaching kids in
school at least in this one school i
mean this is this is
this is really crazy stuff man i mean
look at these photos they're showing
kids
it's like a bunch of why are they
showing kids this
you know i grew up on the south side of
chicago i grew up in a classroom full of
uh people hispanic people from different
backgrounds sam south norwalk
i grew up with people some black people
because it's south side of chicago with
kids i should say people just a bunch of
kids all different types
filipino kid kid from poland uh black
kid
mexican kid one kid spoke spanish one
kid spoke polish
didn't mean anything and guess what when
we were growing up we were like
racism is bad because you're you're
these are my friends
now they're just you know jamming this
into the face of kids
and it's like cult of zealotry it's just
some of the weirdest stuff
i've ever seen but you've you've got i
don't know how much how personal you
want to get
yeah sure what are your what are your
thoughts on this because i think this
affects you i mean i'm
scared for you know
my daughter to have to
just physically wear a mask all day to
me
is torturous like i feel so much
empathy for people who have to do that
and have to go to jobs and wear that all
day that
that just seems insane but
then to the what the creepy part that we
talked about is that the whole class is
gonna be live streamed
like they're in class they're in class
but the kids who are remote
are who are not coming to school can
still participate so there's like
there's definitely cameras on
all day and they're all on their where's
it streaming to
so anybody can it's being recorded
probably so you can zoom bomb it
i don't know what the deal is with how
you just lock down this but yeah i don't
know
i know that there was that we mentioned
the patreon court case earlier
somebody accidentally had their
microphone on and so the judge is like
who's that turn that off i got to kick
somebody out of the room
like how crazy is that i mean i get you
can walk into a courtroom and start
screaming and they'll throw you out
but you could have these kids in these
zoom classes and all of a sudden
some crazy random stranger jumps in and
starts posting like
horrifying things and the kids are going
to see it yeah that happened
yeah there's a little jewish family i
think that had their little
homeschooling pot and somebody got in
and started
mommy anti-semitic stuff the scarier
thing to me though
is the idea that you can't really have
trouble makers in class and that you
know the troublemakers are going to
be on camera that's just not how it's
supposed to be
kids are supposed to be a little
rambunctious yeah learn what it's like
in the room you have no idea they
don't even know what it means to be
streaming
did you see the uh there was this viral
thread from a teacher saying
i'm worried about parents finding out
now what we're teaching their kids
i didn't see that's that's the scariest
thing and he like locked his account
afterwards he did
it was a full thread of this guy being
like i'm worried about the conservatives
they start they'll start seeing what
we're teaching their children
i'm also worried about the liberals too
and it's like
these these teachers know full well
they're indoctrinating children with
zealous fanaticism and they're scared
people are going to find out now because
of covid
i think man it's time to get out of the
city it's time to pull your kids out
homeschooling is intense it's a lot of
energy
but i i do you know i'm very open to it
i i think that if you look at how
rapidly
kids learn i mean there's there's a ton
of value
to be going to school yeah for social
reasons but
you know when they all have to stand in
a little bubble being for apparently
they're going to force the kids to play
games in little bubbles
outside at the local school so like
there's no recess there's no just going
out and playing on the playground that's
not allowed the playgrounds are off
limits but they're going to put them
outside into these little circles and
they have to play like a board game
outside and not wear a mask this is the
cr this is some of the crazy stuff you
know
i remember when i was little not when i
was little but i was like younger as a
teenager
i always thought you know times change
and you don't want to be that person who
gets stuck in the past
you know older people become
conservative and they talk about how
things used to be so much better
and i always thought like you know what
times change but this is some kind of
ridiculous
psychosis you know it's one thing i'm
growing up and it's like by the way
you know gay people can get married now
and i'm like this affects me in no way i
don't care
now it's literally like you can't go to
the movies you can't go to a bar
what's that you went to a park and you
weren't wearing a mask you're under
arrest
we're going to kick your door and we're
going to shut your business down now the
kids are going to be in bubbles
out whatever i don't know circles it's
like oh i painted circle on the ground
but i mean i wouldn't be surprised
if if there were bubbles i mean they're
putting up they're putting up plexi
between
the desks and they have to wear masks
this is insane yeah for for what
look i understand there's there's
there's covid but i mean
you look at the metrics it does not
justify
what everyone is doing uh sweden didn't
lock down
and they they had some problems and now
things are kind of slowing down
it really does look like early on we had
a problem
and we did the 15 days slow the spread
we certainly did
now we got a bunch of cases and nobody's
going to the hospital
it's just it's hysteria it's a stereo
driven by
we are locked in this culture where the
left is at the wheel
and then nothing can check them so
they're just spinning the wheel as crazy
as possible
and the left thinks trump's driving but
he's not and the switch
from covid to protest
riots with with no question to me that
was there was so much dissonance in my
head
i was i was bugging out for like a few
days just
nobody else seeming to to care
and i thought i mean i saw you made some
posts and you were just like
i it's it's over i i don't care anymore
oh i'm done
yeah no it's straight up done the moment
the riots the protests i'm like
you cannot make me care anymore no no i
can care about the authoritarian
lockdowns sorry man look
we we we are taking precautions here you
know bill came down we've got sanitizer
we're you know we're distanced and all
that stuff and we're being careful
just because i think it's responsible i
don't wanna i'm not gonna be one of
these
i you see these stories of these guys
who are like it's all fake yeah and then
they get sick and they die
i'm like no no no no look i recognize
there's
you know we've got something but at this
point i think
we've probably we've probably developed
heart immunity or something
why are we at 152 days of lockdown
because we can't
talk about it i run the risk of being
banned for simply saying this i'm not
even kidding yeah
you had you had you saw those doctors
get get
uh facebook banned those doctors for
holding a pr i'm sorry they banned
breitbart
for filming doctors hosting a pres
putting on a press conference hosted by
a republican yeah newsguard changed
their status
negative yeah but they they put it into
uh like uh they were considering it
again
right right they've removed their green
check and they're like oh we're not sure
about breitbart anymore so if i
if i film a press conference i could get
i could get shut down
so i mean i feel like you've already
sort of taken the stance that
you're going to within reason talk about
what you want to talk about despite it
being controversial and it seems like
i i honestly think that based on your
intention
which is pretty clear that you're just
trying to get information out you're
having an honest take on
on what's going on that you just have to
hope that the tech overlords are going
to
just get it that you know coming coming
at it from a good place and you have to
be able to talk about these things
so with with youtube i have a direct
contact right
and when my videos get demonetized i
basically send them in
and i would say 99 of my videos
about 95 are monetized
like this there's been big changes over
the past few years it's been fantastic
they've they've
uh just recently in the past few months
i've been finally granted
on my second channel tim cast news uh
i've been granted
what's called self-certification which
means now almost every video i do is
getting monetized
however this is what's really messed up
about the whole system
i have like i don't know what 1500
videos on one channel
and 29 of them are incorrectly
certified so here's how it works i
upload a video it says
do any of these things appear in your
video i put no i don't swear
i don't show graphic images well someone
for some reason thought that me
criticizing black lives matter was hate
speech
so they flag it now i have 29 out of
1500
so now youtube's put me in this thing
where they have to do a pending ad
like they put you in a 20-minute holding
pattern
every time you upload so that's actually
been very detrimental
so then whenever i get one of these
false flags i got to send a huge
list to google like all of these are
wrong like there's no hate speech in any
of my content
and they can't do all of them because
it's a combination of an automated
system
and then certain people get access to
you know uh google employees who will do
an override
and they still can't do every single one
well mines.comcast is fully monetized
yeah yeah yeah well well we've got uh
teamcast.comcast.net
going to be that's going to be the way
to do it so uh for those that aren't
familiar
teamcast.net used to redirect to my main
youtube channel
now it's set up to redirect to
essentially
like i don't know how do you i don't
want to describe it it's a it's a site
powered by mines
right so it's basically we've talked
about this before that we're going to be
setting up a standalone website for
the podcast for my other shows that you
can go you can become a member get
exclusive content all stuff and it's
being built
through like the mines pro backend i
guess and
i don't i don't want to speak too much
as to how it works but people who are
signed up can use
minds or whatever yeah yeah you can log
in temcast.net
with your minds creds honestly anyone
out there who wants to monetize like
mines is open for monetization so you
have like ads now running and everything
no not ads yet but we're we're
essentially sharing our revenue
yeah with the procreators who help us
drive traffic so we can't have
advertisers come to us and say
you know you have to monetize this
content because we're sharing our
subscription revenue
mine's plus and mine's pro with the
creators who are helping drive traffic
and we're giving competitive rpms so
you know check out my.com pro if you're
interested and
yeah man i mean the general idea for
what i'm trying to do is
creating something that's standalone so
if you know they ban me they ban
any of my channels well i'll still have
timcast.net i'll still exist in some
form and not just simply get wiped out
and so you know minds being a much
better
safer system in my opinion for you know
for speech that's what's being built on
and then you you guys have added like
youtube sync and stuff yep and we
we also have a peer-to-peer advertising
system which i honestly think is sort of
the future of where
brand to brand advertising is going
where actually people right now can send
you
offers on mines of any amount
of dollars or crypto and
saying hey tim here's a thousand bucks
share my post
to your followers and he'll get a
notification that says
hey do you want to accept this offer or
reject it so it's direct
between brands as opposed to having to
go through
us for advertising so right you know if
someone
gets demonetized on youtube like guess
what there's
for everybody who gets demonetized on
youtube there are thousands
of brands who probably would send them a
direct
offer and then they could run the
content yeah and they're
youtube doesn't need to be getting
involved right it's like
i mean i can put ads in my videos no
yeah yeah
that right that works too but but there
was a system that it was automated for
people to send you offers
on youtube that would be sweet the big
brands have that
right on youtube i'm not going to name
any of the big companies but the big
companies apparently
have direct access to the ads that run
on their platform it's ridiculous
you know they should have opened it up a
long time ago but
that would have avoided the apocalypse
problem i guess i think a lot of these
big companies really are scared that
if they do nothing the platform goes
insane you get extremists across the
board and just weird content of like you
know hitler dancing with the incredible
hulk like we've seen
and if they try to do something then
they're invariably going to be favoring
some political ideology
based on their own views or there's no
real way to
other than just let it let it go it's
such a complex problem and i was just
listening to a
a podcast with sam harris and this new
york times reporter who
reports on i don't even want trafficking
or trafficking yes
and um basically you know
acknowledging that you need encrypted
solutions
but that basically like
some ridiculous like over 40 of all
child trafficking reports come from
facebook messenger
really yeah wow and so they're scared
that if you encrypt everything then
there's going to be no access to those
people
yeah but obviously you need to encrypt
everything because if you compromise
encryption it makes everybody less safe
so it's like how do you actually deal
with this and
but but the answer is not create a
backdoor right
the answer is not censor everything that
has this word and it has to be
a more nuanced solution and we just have
to have a more open conversation about
it and
like the the the platforms are so
powerful
that they they can
step up and make the decisions i mean
i was just on a call a live stream with
a bunch of like the president aclu
um a couple high-level people from
they've lost it in the social in the
sense of their social media
but they do still from what they were
saying uphold these values and
they they we were actually there were
some de-radicalization former radicals
on the call former uh jihadi recruiter
was on the call
who works with daryl davis wow and he
basically
started this this group parallel
networks which is de-radicalization
group that goes on social networks and
tries to
help help bring people back from the
from the edge but you know they were
agreeing
with it and so i i do think
that this the smartest people in the
world
know and i'm not saying these are the
smartest people in the world i'm saying
but all the cyber security encroachment
encryption
experts know that you have to encrypt
everything
yeah and all of the de-radicalization
experts know that you can't ban
everybody
and so they're beholden to the mob
that's it
that every everybody knows you can't do
this everybody mob
if in like you're saying the mob doesn't
even actually want
de-radicalization because
if you look at the data and you actually
want to minimize even if you wanted to
minimize hate speech
banning makes more hate speech so right
and they don't get that but yeah they
don't get that they're like look we
banned this person they've gone away
forever have you changed anything no
no the number of people who have
called for bannings have never changed
anybody's mind
they've been banned that's what's funny
it's like you know uh there was a comic
that got banned recently
and it was this it was a black woman
wearing a mask and her shirt said i
can't breathe and the white
white woman looks over and said
something like you know well then take
the mask off
and that was the comic i gotta chuckle
out of it it got censored i think from
instagram or somewhere
for being not not from instagram from
some company or something
for being a from a newspaper that's what
it was it was offensive and they started
complaining about it and i'm like
welcome to the party you want offensive
content removed now you get removed
it affects them you know and they don't
learn but i look at these big tech
companies
yeah you're right they know all these
things i don't believe the aclu
actually has civil liberties at heart
they oppose civil liberties
so how can i trust them to i'll give you
an example
they've supported discrimination against
minorities at universities
straight up no questions asked not
hyperbole not an exaggeration
they say it is okay for universities to
discriminate against someone based on
their race
that's not civil liberties so how can i
trust them to actually have
to do the right thing when sure they can
be on the phone and they can say things
like oh yeah yeah we we know we're going
to do the right thing
and then they turn around and they spit
on the constitution or they spit on
civil rights
they do still represent some
extreme racists in certain cases but
it's you know by far the minimum
of the legal work that they're doing and
it seems like their social media has
become totally
polarized so you know when
when when you talk to the the aclu and
you you grow them about these issues
they they do
still try to hold on but yeah no
i'm i'm over it it's like it's like jack
dorsey they whisper everything you want
to hear into your ears
and then do nothing and you look at you
look at how they act on social media and
the things they inflame the things they
empower
and it's insanity and it's and it's part
of the ongoing problem
we can't have honest conversations
because of companies like the aclu
because they won't stand up for free
they're the ones who we need to be
standing up
they won't they turn their back on free
speech they've straight up turned their
back on it
and you can look at these organizations
that are advocating for i think
the funniest thing revelation or you
know
something thing to happen was the free
press.net
the free press organization supporting
censorship
like they literally have multiple
initiatives on censoring content
like you're called free press dude
that's how insane
everyone has gotten and i believe it's
because
everyone feels like they're forced to
say certain things because everyone
around them
you know it's the weirdest thing yeah
like nobody really wants this but
everyone's scared everyone else wants it
i guess
if it feels like some sort of a thought
virus
it it it's so much fear people are just
terrified of of social backlash
and but i honestly think that
the again i'm a broken record but
ultimately the data is just gonna
destroy the arguments i i i i want to
believe
that the data about censorship is just
going to prove itself
and people and it's just like no data
data i don't think so
i don't think i don't think so like we
we've known these things for a long time
we fought for these rights we fought for
uh you know
to to be able to speak freely to be able
to associate to be able to communicate
journalists used to be able to sit down
with
warlords now you do that and they call
you a minion of the warlord
and so you can have all the data in the
world i can publish on twitter all day
and night look at these things
doesn't matter because you know listen
you look at the science and the data
around covid you'll get banned
you you post about fbi crime stats you
get banned
you can't talk about these things dude
other countries think we're nuts
they do we we just got like a quarter
million users from thailand who are
freaking out about
their government and censorship in their
from their government
like we have more censorship from
corporations
yeah in the us than our government every
other country
it's like no the government is saying
you cannot criticize them
that's where we're at we have the first
amendment
but these big companies have have taken
over the commons and
whatever the left is today's is
hilarious donald trump talked about
pardoning edward snowden
yep and the aclu tweeted out this is one
thing where we're
we say yes to and they got attacked
relentlessly
how dare you defend the president the
orange man is bad
this should not be it was they got
roasted on twitter saying no he's a
criminal
that's who they've attracted you know
and this is what what really bothers me
about
people the things they do the things
they say the things they chase
the aclu should take a good long look in
the mirror
and look at the people they've attracted
because they don't believe in
in civil liberties like you know you can
complain that there are people who
follow me and comment
and they say naughty words i believe in
free speech
as long as i'm not breaking the law and
inciting the violence well i don't i
don't appreciate what they say but i
think they have a right to say it
aclu is the opposite they're they're
they're the anti-civil liberties union
at this point i'm ranting about the aclu
but it's funny though that you say they
did acknowledge that so i would i would
put
them in sort of a part of the
progressive realm
that like greenwald and
snowden even who and you know the
those who they have values they do have
some standards i agree with you that
they've gotten unhinged but they did say
they agree with that because they had to
because they tweeted like a couple years
ago
and the tweet still exists and people
highlighted it laughing at them and they
said no no we believe that
but look at what happened with
charlottesville they came out and
defended free speech of charlottesville
got attacked and started bleeding
subscribers and then apologized and said
oh we're going to review our first
amendment you know
approach from now on isn't that crazy
imagine the
money that the aclu would get if they
got the actual free speech community to
start supporting them like
the free speech community on the
internet is not giving money to the aclu
right and it's like the people listening
to this right now
if the aclu would stand up for free
speech they would get huge surge
of subscriptions like
it unites the factions of the left man
from progressive
far left to moderate corporate dems to
passive liberals whatever
they all hate trump and that's the go-to
yeah it's funny it's like
there you you sort of have to pick which
crowd of monthly subscribers you want
well yeah yeah or you just stay true to
yourself
and people will come and go and some
people will complain
and you get emails where they're like
you've changed man we don't we don't
like the direction you're going and i
say i can only do me
you know what i do what i want to do no
one's going to tell me what i can do
you know well then reason like you know
if you want to if they're going to ban
me from social media well then so be it
i'm going to do my thing
but nobody's gonna tell me what i have
to do i just do what i feel like doing
what makes me happy
and that's all i've ever done well you
you are a principled person and you are
just one person so it might be a little
more complicated for the aclu
so i understand kind of where they're
coming from but if they were principled
at all
they would just say you know what we
just support all free speech and if you
want to stop supporting us because we
support everyone's free speech fine the
fact that we support everyone's free
speech means that more people will be
along later to give us money
i think that would be great it's a long
game yeah exactly yep
but everybody is what i i think if i was
going to try and paint a picture of what
was happening
it's that everybody is sitting staring
at each other side-eyed
panicked like which one's gonna be the
one to get me dude i
am terrified by the fact that even just
on this stream
it's just like watching what we say you
said the r word i said the r word
i said sorry to you because i felt bad
because you could potentially
lose monetization on it and it's just
like that
is not where the focus needs to be it's
so stupid
yeah thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you